hey youtubers what's up so this is gonna
be my agent Carter episode 3 video
nice deep cutting into Jarvis this is
actually I felt like much more of a
Jarvis episode than it was a Peggy
Carter episode we also got to meet a new
character who might turn out to be
someone special the person that's
playing dotty like the new character
she's rose from Jane the virgin she was
in a bunch of those episodes she was
also in a bunch of white-collar episodes
too she's supposed to be a ballet dancer
so I'm wondering if she's gonna be tied
to this Leviathan plot just because
Leviathan is a Russian organization the
ballet thing also kind of made me think
of that shot in the age of Ultron
trailer with the dancers okay so careful
for spoilers from the episode and what
I'm gonna do in this video just gonna be
a little bit different than before I'm
gonna do my top five moments and then
I'll do my top five thumb thumbs down
instead of giving it like a regular
rating so starting off top five moments
number five spider-man does not know the
rules of the house I guess you could
also take this is like a daredevil joke
too I thought of it more as a Spider Man
thing it's just a brief moment of comedy
that you know like creepy stalker guy
climbing up the drainpipe turns out to
be some horndog trying to get to the
girl next door I did like the way they
followed up on it with the breakfast
later on but I feel like the nighttime
scenes like these covert funny nighttime
scenes are gonna be way more rewarding
in terms of this boarding house it just
feels like that's where the action is
gonna be you know if it's an
impenetrable fortress and getting above
the first floor is like the big deal
then obviously people trying to get
above the first floor is what's gonna be
exciting I feel like if they wanted to
take the joke just a step further they
would have just had her punch him right
in the face and he would have just
fallen off to the street I guess I guess
it was too high that would have been
kind of dark he probably have broken his
back number four
agent Sousa and SSR double down on Stark
in the mystery tipster they were
actually quite a few bummer moments in
this episode like a lot of Peggy getting
thrown under the bus and as much as
Sousa is her supporter like behind the
scenes like he really supports Peggy
inside the SSR he's really going after
this tipster like he's trying to connect
the tipster to the professional hit
meaning that he's going to be chasing
down Peggy it just ups the threat level
for them discovering that Peggy is the
tipster because if they do find out at
least at this point she's definitely
going to jail it also seems like they
all want to shoot stark in the face like
they really want to hate him I imagine a
lot of people feel the same way about
Tony Stark too they just want to walk up
and punch him in the face
this seems a little extreme though this
is like one of the few things I had an
issue
at this point all we know is that Starck
built the weapons and then someone came
along and stole them I don't know if
there's a deeper connection it seems
like there might be something else going
on that we just don't know yet about
what Stark has been up to number-3 Peggy
does not mind jumping on the occasional
grenade
I knew Peggy was going to create a
diversion somehow I just I didn't know
that she was gonna throw herself on that
grenade just to be clear he could shoot
a little confused what she did is is
claimed she messed up the paperwork on
the missing car so Jarvis used the cars
the excuse he's like oh I've reported
that missing but they couldn't find the
paperwork so Peggy used that I was a
little surprised with how badly they
blew their stacks this is like the first
big instance of Peggy getting thrown
under the bus like not only can she not
take credit for all these big wins she
also has to get yelled at all day like
it's not enough that people make rude
comments about her now they're just like
straight up yelling in her face this is
obviously gonna make the payoff that
much sweeter whenever she's vindicated
but who knows when that's gonna happen
like is it gonna be the final episode
like in the finale or will the carrying
into season two I feel like they have to
give her a big win at some point like
they can't keep doing this to her
without giving her some giant win and
she really didn't get one in this
episode did anyone else think about
Captain America throwing himself on the
grenade in the first movie I feel like
Peggy instantly knew what she was gonna
do although I do think it was really
smart of them to include that scene at
the diner like she really is getting
ready to cry she's not a human model
decoy like she has feelings that scene
in the automat actually reminded me of
the end credits scene in Iron Man 3
whenever Tony Stark was pouring his
heart out to Bruce Banner but she was
getting ready to let all her feels out I
am a little bit worried for the amount
of trust that she's placing in Angie
like we really don't have a reason to
trust Angie at this point Lyndsy Fonseca
is a pretty big character it's I think
it's implied that she's going to be good
person I don't I don't think she's evil
but I feel like she's hiding something
like there'll be some deeper layer to
her character that we don't know about
yet this show is like a Marvel spy
thriller TV show so no one character is
ever going to be just exactly what you
see there's always going to be some sort
of secret that they have so I'm really
interested to learn what Angie's secret
is on to number two Leviathan covers
their tracks this mystery group of
people here that came up and killed
agent Krasinski in the witness they
could have been Leviathan they could
have been Roxanne or they could be some
other group that we haven't met yet I
don't think I don't think they'll get
too complicated like the only
big organizations that we know about at
this point are the SSR Leviathan and
Roxon so it's one of those three and I
don't think it's an inside job although
I wouldn't be surprised given all the
Winter Soldier Hydra infiltration stuff
if there are Leviathan people inside the
SSR we really aren't even halfway
through the season so they're still
building for that big reveal
like who this organization really is
like what's going on I think when we
learn who Leviathan is we'll find out
who these people are that are cleaning
up all over town I do want to believe
that Roxanne is connected to Leviathan
there's been this big teaser about
shaping the future there are a couple
people that have capabilities to do that
there are people with technology like
Howard Stark money and power and the
other person that has a lot of money in
power is Ray wisest character really
still more questions than answers at
this point and I'm expecting that to
continue all the way through episode
four I think it'll be like episode 6 or
7 before we get any kind of big villain
reveals and my number one moment
Jarvis back story explained deep dive
into Jarvis this is actually one of my
favorite things about the episode just
listening to Jarvis talk about himself
most of my experience with the Avengers
and Jarvis are with the more recent
comics and I think it's really like the
classic Avengers comics that deal more
with the Edwin Jarvis character so
there's a lot that I've missed they are
taking some liberties with the character
like this is the new Marvel Universe the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that they're
working inside of but I do feel like
there are probably a lot of Easter eggs
for people that are fans of the classic
comic at first glance he does seem like
an Alfred Pennyworth type character you
know former RAF except the fact that he
got dishonorably discharged I do like
the setup that he has principles like
he's a very noble person very loyal and
he's totally willing to break the rules
for the right reasons I feel like that's
the DNA of the Avengers right there
they're good people but they do break
the rules all the time it also makes the
Howard Stark character more sympathetic
he probably saw what Jarvis was doing
and then wanted to help him out thus he
came to be Starks Alfred Pennyworth I
also really appreciated that they made
his wife more of a character they
actually gave her a couple lines in the
episode we heard her for the first time
I wonder if it's gonna be a muppet
babies situation with her character like
we never see her face we only hear her
talking off screen or we only we only
see other characters looking at her we
never see her full-on so here are my big
questions for you guys what was your
favorite moment from the episode and how
long do you think it's gonna be before
agent Sousa finds out that agent Carter
is the anonymous tipster right now I
feel like that's the big T's like
they'll kind of develop their
relationship a little bit like they'll
deal more with the you know do you
really like Peggy how does Peggy feel
about agent Sousa and then eventually
he'll find out that she's the tipster
and it'll cause a bunch of chaos I
wouldn't be surprised that that also
happened around the time that we found
out who the real villain was it's like a
bunch of little fuses for these
different bombs that are all going to go
off at the same time okay so now time
for my top five thumbs down
you know these are just like things that
I felt like did not work in the episode
so Dooley in the SSR being over the top
[ __ ] all the agents are even being
[ __ ] to themselves all the male
agents I feel like it's a little too
over the top I think I think on the page
it works just fine but the actors
performances were just a little extreme
like especially Dooley's like I want
Stark's head like yes we get it
an agent died Europe said but you're
supposed to be the boss you're supposed
to be the smart person here look I
understand like what they're going for
what the tone is meant to imply it just
feels like they're acting in a stage
play and they're trying to shout to the
back row so my next um they're really
like two thumbs down so like double
thumbs down on like the morning like the
day boarding room scenes mrs. fry is the
new Red Skull and the breakfast scene I
felt like this dragged a little bit I
was really hoping for something awesome
with the Harry Houdini reveal but she
just threw Molly under the bus all the
fun stuff happens at night so I'd like
to spend more time at the boarding house
at night I guess you could look at it as
setup like they're trying to set up
something happening there at night like
someone breaking in and something crazy
will happen otherwise they wouldn't beat
us over the head with the second floor
being like such an impenetrable place so
my last thumbs down is actually Peggy
just getting shot in the face
continuously in this episode I wonder
how long it's gonna be before they give
her a big win like if they're just gonna
keep slapping her in the face like she
can't take credit for any of these wins
now the SSR is chasing after her like
they're trying to connect her to
Leviathan who they don't even know
exists and then they spend all day just
screaming in her face and telling her
she's incompetent I felt like the downer
ending was totally on purpose they just
want Peggy to start trusting other
people and obviously someone's going out
to betray that trust at some point I
wonder if it's gonna be Angie or if it's
gonna be Dottie like this new character
if he spotted any other Easter eggs in
the episode that I didn't
just write them below in the comments so
next week will be another new episode
will be Episode four be sure to
subscribe to get that I am gonna be
doing a Q&A just because the Ultron
trailer dropped everyone has a bunch of
questions about that as well as the
Black Panther character that everyone
was wondering about last night so I'll
do a Q&A tomorrow night there's also
gonna be a new arrow trailer for arrow
season 3 so I'll post a video for that
tomorrow too
so right now if you haven't seen it like
20 or 30 times already here's a link to
the age of Ultron trailer the new
trailer and click here to catch up on
agent Carter for last week's episode
thank you so much for watching so that's
all high five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you